[Music]
yeah I got into the habit of trying to
animate things separately you know to
make everything you know flow around on
the paper correctly now to animate ahead
and this was a little mermaid and then I
would animate the body and then I would
I would animate things separately so I
could keep track of them so they were
they would move correctly right but then
I started getting into trouble like oh
that has to move from frame 1 to 7 and
the head should move on Keys 3 to 9 and
then the feet from you know and I would
have least charts going on on the paper
and it got really confusing and
complicated and then I went back to
Milt's work and when he's got one chart
he's got one chart he has one one chart
it's so annoying what is he doing and I
would talk about it we don't erase a
little bit and and and and and also I
did talk about it a little bit with Stan
green um one of Milt's old assistants
and it really basically came to realize
that that um he just did a lot of it
himself and he would structure these
things where he would do these major key
drawings and then he would go in and
fill in all the little details all the
flamboyant little parts on every single
drawing but he wouldn't do a whole
drawing he would do a partial drawing
and then you would fill in the rest or
the balance but he was so far ahead in
the process he was thinking two or three
steps ahead that he could figure out
where things were gonna be in space so
that you would be then be able to the
assistant could fill in the rest of the
drawings and the whole thing would like
come together in a one sort of final act
you know the house of cards would just
sort of build itself I still look at
that melts work today I still read the
illusion of life because you know I find
out something new you know every time I
do but I chose Jungle Book with King
Louie the introduction of King Louie
rich milk did my staff thought I'd put
one of my monkeys up there next to it
and did a piece of Rafiki and I did look
at jungle but you know desperately
trying to now
I can't copy this account copy this and
they in the you know I did copy
something I copied the elbow here
totally ripped it off
I just that looks cool
and I did I had I had a drawing of King
Louie there you know one of the two
really nice first roughs you know the
Xerox of them you know on the wall but
the thing I sort of took away from the
King Louie was he's animating a person
you know it's a it's a human in an
animal's body which is what all these
Disney animal films are but what I took
away from it was the sense that how odd
you could be with an ape or a monkey and
some of the contortions that King Louie
would get into I sort of felt would be
appropriate for this sort of slightly
crazed Rafiki character and so parts
where he turns his head upside down
you
[Music]